as we continue on this Sunday morning
James Pinkerton who is a columnist with
Newsday good morning thanks very much
for joining us and Christopher Hitchens
who is the contributing editor for
Vanity Fair what are you reading today I
like should I hold it up the director
you've got I like the Iranian election
results a lot and I like the victory of
what they're always called moderates but
I because I have a long memory
and a taste for this kind of thing I'd
like to point out these moderates of one
without having any covert injections of
American weapons to them in fact they
seem to have one as a result of the
isolation of Iran by all democratic
regimes so their lesson there for those
of us with long memories and possibly
good news for someone often in my
thoughts a friend and comrade of mine
Salman Rushdie about whom it's just
possible that this new regime may want
to reconsider the absurdity of suborning
the murder of novelists for money in the
name of God so anyway it gave me a lift
to see this at the beginning of my
Sunday and he is not interested at least
for the moment in resuming any type of
normal relations with this country no
well I think he would have been bound to
say that first off fully Oh probably was
a dumb question to ask him on day one
but and for the moment this country
isn't interested either but at least
we've now broken the connection between
Iranian moderates and American covert
action mr. Pinkerton what are you ready
I think the most exciting news in
historical perspective is the
anniversary of the Marshall Plan is
coming up on June 5th is 50 years ago
that Secretary of State Marshall
launched a great aid program to war-torn
Europe and you just had the fellow from
France talking about the French
elections and the reason they have free
elections there is in large part because
of the wisdom of President Truman
secretaries day chosen and of course
President Clinton is going to Europe
this week to talk about NATO expansion
which i think is actually a mistake but
the overall success of the Marshall Plan
is undeniable and ranks as one of the
great successes of American foreign
policy in our history so welcome back to
the data which in a moment but you asked
me to show this to our viewers is Humber
immediately after World War two and then
in 1950 following the Marshall Plan why
did you want to show this well it's just
a great before and after as Winston
Churchill said the Marshall Plan was the
most generous act ever taken by a victor
against a defeated country and of course
it affected all of Europe and the United
States even offered Marshall Plan aid to
the Soviet Union and its Eastern Bloc
countries which Stalin rejected in
today's dollars it would amount to about
eighty eight billion dollars Christopher
Hitchens in money that we contributed to
Europe how do you think this plan would
sell today well though I I know what so
instant Churchill meant by saying it was
the the least selfish imaginable act as
a matter of fact there's a perfectly
good case to be made for it in point of
self-interest and I'm sure self-interest
wasn't absent from the deliberations of
you by recovering or helping to recover
the economies of Western and Central
Europe the United States hugely increase
in certain opportunities for trade and
for investment in expansion and
prosperity and so it was all money well
spent and would be again at today's
prices Gregory fossa Dell who is the
author of historian has this piece in
The Weekly Standard it's called foreign
aid that worked he writes at the
Marshall Plan in this view worked not
because it was an act of generosity an
extension of the New Deal he says it
worked because it fit in with other
great post-war free-market economic
reforms the liberalization of Commerce
under the GATT treaties the
stabilization of currencies through a
number of Bretton wood agreement systems
and also the study of the economic
performance of participating countries
giving a nuanced picture of what it
would mean for post-war Europe well I'm
inclined to agree with that
perhaps Christopher is not but the thing
is there like any great event and the
Marshall Plan certainly was great
statecraft for the United States as well
as altruism the Marshall Plan could be
used to justify open trade and current
stabilization of currencies it can also
be used to justify greater foreign aid
because somebody could say we need a
Marshall Plan for Africa or a Marshall
Plan you here at home for the cities
it's again like anything you can
interpret it different ways
Greg frost Adele by the way is the
director of the Alexis de Tocqueville
Institute which we're going to be
talking about
not the Institute but alexis de
tocqueville later in the program I
wanted what he'd do once he ran out of
arguments for Star Wars that's what that
used to be his job I'm glad to find that
he's gone straight we're gonna get to
your phone calls the number is on the
bottom of the screen and we're welcoming
as we do each and every Sunday our
viewers in this country and those
watching overseas in Great Britain on
the parliamentary Channel our first call
is from Canton Ohio good morning hello
questions a couple comments of your law
I mean one is 50 Iranians Iraq Saudi
Arabia I had called their Embassy as
well as a Chinese Embassy about their
anti-christian bias we save the Saudi
Arabians and the Kuwait ease from their
own brothers they would not allow a
Christian cross a Bible or American flag
on their soil there's a lot of
atrocities against Christians in those
countries but yet the United States
allows total freedom when those folks
come here but they have an
anti-christian bias as question number
one number two Washington Post captain
Graham I'm sorry Washington Times had
reported that Katherine Graham saw that
uh Richard Nixon went down but would not
she didn't think that Clinton should go
down yet I think Nixon crimes compared
to Clinton's are very minor like to have
some in-depth comment on if possible
thank you kitchens well it is true that
in Saudi Arabia not only is the practice
of Judaism and Christianity forbidden
but also the practice of certain kinds
of Islam that don't conform to the
Wahhabi orthodoxy of the ruling family
but it isn't true of the other countries
you mentioned sir I mean in for example
in Damascus very old biblical City
there's a very large Christian community
much of it Armenian but also Arab and
Syrian as well as many Druze and in Iraq
there are many Nestorian and Chaldean
Christians indeed the Saddam Hussein's
detestable foreign minister Tariq Aziz
is a Nestorian or Chaldean Christian I
forget which denomination he he
professes and in Iran there are reserved
seats in the
action that they've just had for
religious minorities including
Zoroastrians and Jews so that though
it's bad to be a Baha'i follower in Iran
I think it ought to be better known that
our great friend Saudi Arabia follows
this policy just as it should be better
known that our great friend Saudi Arabia
shelters IDIA mean war criminal and mass
murderer of Uganda on the grounds that
he represents Islam in Uganda which i
think is an insult to Islam and to
Uganda both on your second point the
pure nonsense I mean I know one
criticizes some President tension I
think more than I do
but compared to Richard Nixon is to is
to exaggerate absurdly that he is not
committing high crimes and misdemeanors
in the same way he hasn't bombed
Cambodia on the quiet he hasn't used the
IRS and the FBI to witch-hunt his
political enemies not yet I wouldn't say
wasn't capable of it and he hasn't
broken his oath to uphold the
Constitution well of course he will see
about the FBI and that it does appear
that somebody the White House was
looting the FBI files pretty thoroughly
I think the caller makes a good point
about the persecution of Christians
around the world in in some places China
Vietnam Sudan there is quite a bit of
going on and it's very unfortunate and
it's something that the United States is
going to have to deal with what else you
reading today um I think this is I'm not
a trained in legal journalism but this
looks to me like Mark Fisher here in the
post has got a genuine scoop on this
business about trial lawyers who I think
I've become replacing the power of
federal regulators as the most energetic
people affecting the way corporations do
business with private sector or class
action tort lawsuits they have apparent
to the coordinates article the trial
lawyers have set up a secret group
called a complex litigation committee
which organizes and orchestrates
class-action suits
around the country they use the power of
technology to set up databases and so
anytime there's a complex a suit of
whether it's breast implants or tobacco
or computers or securities allegations
they get together and there's a fellow
in California named John Doerr who led
the fight against this evil proposition
211 last year which was a on securities
lawsuits calls mechanic's terrorists and
I think we're going to see in the future
the era of big government may be over
but the era when buccaneering trial
lawyers with tort lawsuits are able to
loot millions and billions of dollars
out of the productive economy in this
case for example there was some minor
litigation over because the size of
computer screens and so all the people
who got a computer screen that was the
wrong scientists get a 13 dollar rebate
on their next purchase and meanwhile the
trial lawyers divide up 5.8 million well
I must say I had this story on my list
too but I had his number five as a story
that while interesting did not belong on
the front page because if we could have
mr. Pinkertons headline back again on
the screen I don't know if it could
still go up but I would say I'll read it
anyway class actions big winners the
lawyers is the best version of the dog
bites man headline I think we're likely
to see this year what healthy rating
today I've got some horrible chunk of
the New York Times here about how a
capital punishment human sacrifice in
other words human sacrifice to make the
society feel better
norine taxes in Texas is becoming more
and more aware life and how even the
timing of these human sacrifices is
being scheduled to suit the convenience
of waters so that they don't have to
stay up late usually degrees to be a
student in midnight which while grizzly
gave the chance of people who have jobs
to be able to turn up and protest at the
prison now they're held in working out
as part of the normal coated ian day and
it does but it's not to raise a murmur
or a pulse and because it makes it
harder if people to turn up and share
their
disapproval but I think that the routine
ization and bureaucratization of capital
punishment of human sacrifice in this
case in Texas but spreading across the
country is one of the most depressing
and revolting aspects of our modern
arrangements fifteen men they've all
been met have been executed so far this
year and since 1976 when the Supreme
Court allowed the death penalty Texas
has had 122 louisiana 24 california for
Pennsylvania to Virginia 39 Georgia 22
Florida 39 none in New York none in New
Hampshire and Vermont in other
northeastern states know that if the
splendid Marion Barry has his way we'll
soon have a divot in Washington
something that well nevermind not for
him but I mean he now thinks that um
that it would be just out there for a
city that can't do absolutely anything
at all right should being able to carry
out human sacrifice estimators what if
his officers involved I think is still
usually some constellation I know I'm
Joe did get that Roger like this just to
say I'm actually for the death penalty
there was a case in Spotsylvania
Virginia recently two little girls were
taken away from the school bus and found
dead in a river 40 miles away and I
would think that whoever did that if
they catch him desserts are definitely
Fort Smith Arkansas good morning
gentlemen
my question to you is that you've
mentioned the Marshall Plan I read that
the basic document on which our country
was founded really was the Declaration
of Independence which says that in order
to secure these rights governments are
instituted among men deriving their just
powers from the consent of the
government so I asked myself where in
the Constitution does it authorized the
government of United States to give
money to foreign powers and get involved
in the saving England in World War one
and World War two what if you can answer
that well for wanting your questions of
the Declaration of Independence and then
looking for a source in the Constitution
for the second that is the right
Congress and the Senate
if the president proposes a third it
isn't giving money as we just explained
to you it was a way of an investment and
alone I mean the idea I just went to the
Roosevelt Memorial consecration the
other day and it still makes me laugh
when people say that he so selflessly
came to came to the aid giving American
aid to the United Kingdom during the
Second World War nothing of the kind for
every clapped out American destroyer
sent by lend-lease Roosevelt demanded
and got a british-based either in the
West Indies or in western Africa by the
end of the war in fact had inherited the
greater part of the British Empire so if
you're worried about people thinking of
your country as too soft to touch sir
what's your altruistic I think I can put
your mind at rest
the least of your worries a look inside
some of the magazines Vanity Fair this
is May's edition there's also a June one
out with Arnold Schwarzenegger I think
is on the cover of the June Vanity
Fair's on a budget in case some you
wanted to plug my new column I'd love to
but I want to talk about a column from
from this past month but don't show you
that too this is how would something
like this sell on these stands
this cover how did you fare you can't
keep it on the newsstands it leaps off
like a salmon into the arms of the
customers the May edition includes this
article on Robert Hughes from Australia
who is he
Robert Hughes was best known as the art
critic of Time magazine and the narrator
of a wonderful series about modern art
called the shock of the new but he's
just produced a great book and a serious
to go with it which you're about to see
about the history of this country United
States through its through its paint as
an artist so it's a wonderful narrative
a quote that does jump off from the
article says perhaps not since Alexis de
Tocqueville has foreign spectator seen
so much of the American game this is
this is Tocqueville weak in some way on
Caesar
it's Tocqueville year definitely affair
enough well yes I mean I call Bob here's
the marsupial critic he's an Australian
and whereas a lot of of high culture
type writers in America who aren't
Americans tend to be British I think
possibly because of historical
connections in the turn of voice and so
on
Hughes has a double angle a double
perspective on the United States which i
think is pin he's made very good use of
he's at an oblique angle to the culture
you also wrote the introduction for this
book called charles dickens american
notes what did you write about mr.
Dickens well it's not out yet it's a new
Random House edition the next Random
House edition of that will have my
introduction to it
I think it's Dickens his worst book it
was written at a time when it was very
much the fashion among conservatives in
Britain to say that the American
experiment was a failure he wrote he
wrote it with tremendous condescension
and patronization and contempt he didn't
spend much time here he didn't meet many
people he didn't travel very far but he
wrote in a consistently sneering tone of
voice except for his very last chapter
which is on slavery again he only uses
slavery as a stick to beat the idea of
America with but he he had the brilliant
idea borrowed from an abolitionist
pamphlet of printing the want ads in
southern papers that slave owners would
put in the paper for runaway slaves and
giving them the marks and scars and
chain marks and so on by which they
could be recognized it's a horrifying
read and I give it to my students as a
quick take on what reality of slavery
was how does that compare with what
Alexis de Tocqueville saw well de
Tocqueville was a much more my news
observer and also very much more
broad-minded and so I think what was
latent and potential in America in the
1840s in a way that Dickens either
didn't do or chose not to do it was very
it was until well after the Civil War
where of course the British
conservatives supported the Confederacy
it was almost unbroken the fashion in
Britain too to belittle the American
experiment and say that it was over
before it had begun and what West came a
madman just who we think there was so
compassionate and imaginative as Dickens
I think I mean commits his greatest
delinquency in this book by failing even
to attempt that sorry I just follow
anything published when did this
committee notes was written I was
written as a serial for a magazine in
London
during the 1840s I think yes the late
1840s I know I fought sort of funny I
mean the upper classes in America are
consistently Anglo philic yes and yet
the upper class of England are
consistently seeming to be American a
phobic I mean and one
another very much so did that I think
went on being what so I didn't go on
being I mean that that sort of began to
reverse itself in about 1898 when
America went for overseas Empire tip the
Philippines and in Cuba and began to
make us other lives based on anglo-saxon
with the United Kingdom with what I've
considered have been absolutely
calamitous results but at that point
they began to grow back together again
we were in classes you worked in the
Reagan and in the Bush White House why
do those two presidents and a long list
of public officials continue to quote
Alexis de Tocqueville well if you open
up any random page in the two volumes of
democracy in America you've I think this
is what Christopher was getting in you
say gee this this is like it was written
yesterday I mean the the quality of them
from whether it's America is a nation of
sort of joiners and activists or America
is the most religious Anglican Western
country I mean it is certainly true
proof of the phrase the more things
change the more they stay the same
it is Christopher Hitchens alluded to
earlier we're spending a fair amount of
time on this networked if you've watched
any of our programming on Alexis de
Tocqueville not only a look at what he
saw when he came here in the 1830s but
also where we're going as we approach
the new millennium is it worth the
effort do you think is he an important
yes very much so everyone should read
that book and reread it keep it by them
you know yet we'll get a call from Bel
Air Maryland good morning you want to
talk about Susan mcdougal I'll push up
the button go ahead please come in
please
oh I'm sorry we missed the beginning of
what you were about to say start over
hello
yes go ahead please okay there's some
inconsistencies I find in the story
about Susan mcdougal the Baltimore Sun
and I'd like to mention them and then
ask a question if I might sure here's
one note here that Susan mcdougal
falsified her resume and white water
prosecutors characterized that as lies
or I would put it to you gentlemen that
if they were going to
imprison everybody who falsified their
resumes or exaggerated them they
couldn't build business fast enough in
fact I'd venture to say that perhaps you
have may have been guilty of the same
heinous crime
additionally the it points out that the
case against mcdougal the Zubin made
that case which he's going to be tried
in June was originally handed down in
1993 that Starr's request the state
trial was delayed until this year and we
can skip from that where California
judge ordered that miss mcdougal be
returned to the more comfortable Texas
facility but still she continues to be
held in Los Angeles spokesman for stars
that he had no control over where or how
mcdougal is held and seems to be
somewhat inconsistent he could get a
criminal case delayed for four years but
couldn't get her facility transit and
there's one other important thing that
the story doesn't mention which is the
extension of the grand jury term which
traditionally according to all the
various talking had attorneys I've seen
in television lately say has never done
usually people who are jailed for
contempt are released after the term of
the grand jury expires in this case
strangely enough the term of the grand
jury was expended another year okay
caller I'll stop here and either one of
you want to comment though I just say
that just for the benefit of the viewers
I mean Susan mcdougal of course is the
ex-wife of Jim mcdougal who was
convicted of quite a few crimes
associated with whitewater along with
David another person who's in the room
and his celebrated meeting of 1986 a
David Hale and Ken Starr I think
reasonably not wants her to testify at
that she has refused
unless she's given blanket immunity
including for perjury for any testimony
that she might offer and so she's in
contempt of the legal proceedings of
this country and meanwhile and this is a
completely separate case after she
divorced Jim mcdougal left Arkansas she
went to California got a job as sort of
an assistant to the Los Angeles
conductor Zubin Mehta we're on a
completely unrelated matter she was
accused or indicted of embezzling
$150,000 from him and his wife so I must
say that although I've never met her
Susan mcdougal strikes me as kind of a
bad egg and I think she probably
deserves what she's getting US News and
World Report on his cover has road rage
why American drivers are ruder meaner
and more dangerous than ever
Christopher Hitchens any difference
between a British driver and an American
driver no but it's rare to find a phrase
of pop culture phrase transfer from
England to America in this way road rage
was on was the catch phrase on the front
of English magazines about a year ago
normally I find with these kinds of
tendencies they start in America and
then they get picked up in England and
as we've been talking about over the
last couple of days
Kelly Flynn a lieutenant from the US Air
Force the wrong stuff is the cover story
of time and a rather lengthy story
inside Newsweek and an interview in Time
magazine as well with Kelly Flynn I mean
I think the Air Force had a good
position to defend and they did they
handled it badly I mean I mean I'm sure
that your shows at beating subjects of
death over the last few weeks as
everybody else has I mean Kelly Flynn
did three things wrong she had an
adulterous affair she lied about it and
she broke just dissipate in order not to
do it anymore the Air Force led with its
chin on the adultery charge which is
something where they are most subject to
the charge of hypocrisy because probably
lots of male officers do it as well
they should have just slept that one
goes within their discretion and focused
on
but Kelly Flynn admits to which is she
disobeyed an order and lied about and
that would have been enough to drum
around an Air Force I don't know I did
just beats the hell out of me I don't
have any other country in the world we
spent so much time wondering where
babies come from
was this one and in public too I did
notice the two commentators say an
absolutely remarkable thing as if it was
natural normal to them I can't know
which ones they were now but they both
said how can a woman of such low moral
caliber be expected to deliver a nuclear
payload it's at this point I really did
feel I really did feel that there being
a complete inversion in the hierarchy of
ethics and morals but I think by
everything I can discover about issues
absolutely morally up to the job of
delivering a nuclear pilot William
Safire has Arizona lose what part me
just like a guy almost that good
actually that quote that you were just
talking about Sarah Ingram writes about
it this morning the Baltimore Sun fair
treatment for a deliberate liar and the
exact quote is if miss Flynn disobey
direct orders and lied in official
statements do we want her flying
airplanes with nuclear weapons and she
also writes that in a nation that grants
its military officers enormous power and
responsibility do we really want them to
be able to lie when it's convenient I
think the issue here is I mean Chris was
making an arch point about the morality
or immorality of a violence which I
won't argue pretty early what does
matter though if you think about the way
our nuclear deterrent works it is that
we have a very tight chain of command
because we've all seen seven days in May
we all fail safe I mean we have to deal
very closely with these issues you just
don't want irresponsible reckless people
flying around with b-52s full of nuclear
weapons and in the New York time setting
magazine is this article that want to
well show our viewers it's called the
writer is dead but his ghost is thriving
one of the things that readers will
learn from this piece by Jack Hite he
talks about the ultimate secrecy that
involved a call that he got in 1994 to
write an autobiography of a famous
person the name who was not revealed in
the first couple of paragraphs of this
article but later in the piece he writes
about a ghostwriter that is now working
with George Stephanopoulos on a 2.75
million dollar deal to write
Stephanopoulos memoirs about his years
in the White House the buzz now is that
Barnett Bob Barnett who's a Washington
lawyer and I think the husband of Rita
braver CBS News talks about William
Novak who was the ghost writer behind
Lee Iacocca
Oliver North and Magic Johnson he he was
bagged from this book deal what do you
make of ghost writers did you either of
you read the piece by the way no my
agent once put me in for without asking
me to write the was that was that
terrible couple Carville and Matalin
yeah and I remember being thrilled when
I didn't even make the first cut but
then disgusted when I found out how much
money I would have made if I'd been
allowed to sink that low
I think it must be a very horrible way
as a writer to make money and I can't
see why people aren't forced to write
their own books if somebody is given
almost three million or Ronald Reagan I
could see why not because he wasn't
physically or mentally capable of doing
it and his book which was at issue and
was a great publishing Turkey I guess
can be forgiven but I think otherwise
people should be expected to write in
their own in their own voice first
rating has a distinguished history I
mean for example these get less if they
don't I mean profiles and courage which
I don't think anybody really believes
Jack Kennedy had much to do with is an
enduring and great book written by Ted
Sorensen is still alive do you think
that ghost writers are becoming
celebrities people like that William
Novak well I think I read someplace too
way back when that bill Novak wrote
Iacocca for something like forty five
thousand dollars cash cold not no
residuals no points no not long and and
I think he also didn't it might not be
mentioned I think Elsa didn't answer
your Aikens book and now I'm sure he's
in the six seven figures I'm seven
figures I'm sure as a ghostwriter so
it's a I'm sure it is a soul destroying
way to make a living but it does have
its compensations if either of you ever
goes to written a book I know you've
done speeches but I know I haven't even
been asked we got a call from not about
yourself
no as I say my agent put me without
telling me but and I you know I felt
sick twice as was Little Rock Arkansas
good morning good morning I'm glad to
get in this morning talk to your two
distinguished guests they are indeed
they are last week in the Senate there
was a debate over the forty three cents
additional tax on cigarettes and this
was to cover government-funded health
insurance for 10 million children of the
working poor who couldn't afford health
insurance for their children but the
government also tells us but the only
ones that continue to smoke or take up
smoking are the working poor so in other
words they're going to fund their own
government-funded insurance for their
children if those are the bulk of the
smokers in this country or the ones the
newly smokers that you know children
that will begin to smoke are from the
the poor uneducated the working poor
they're actually going to be paying for
their own forced insurance thanks call
it mr. Pinkerton well there was an
interesting sidelight in today's
Washington Post on this matter as the
budget bill was coming to a vote last
week senator hatch a Republican from
Utah and Senator Kennedy of course
Democrat from Massachusetts had an
amendment to include this cigarette tax
providing health insurance and it was
may have its merits or demerits
depending on your point of view but it
was outside of the budget agreement that
Senator Dodd and speaker Gingrich and
President Clinton had negotiated and
they came to a such crunch where it was
very popular bill in the Senate but the
Republican leadership and the Democratic
leadership both came down and crunched
it and there was a story in the post
this morning talking about how a Vice
President Gore in the opinion of Senator
Kennedy's staff misled of Senator
Kennedy about whether or not he'd be
willing to support that piece of
legislation cover of New York Times
Sunday magazine is a profile of Senator
John McCain Republican of Arizona and
a number of paragraphs devoted to
Charles Keating who was an early
contributor to then congressional
candidate John McCain back in 1981-82
when he ran first for the house and
later for the Senate and in this book
and there isn't a relationship the
missionary position Charles Keating is
also referred to in the book by
Christopher Hitchens it's called the
missionary position and you write about
how mother Teresa accepted a large
donation of stolen savings and loan
money from Charles Keating giving him a
crucifix in return and describing this
pious fleece er of the small saber as a
friend of the poor yes and taking rides
on his private jet and interceding with
the court when he was on trial in Los
Angeles saying he was a great friend of
the poor the court wrote her and said
that's all very well but he's given you
lots of money that doesn't belong to him
belongs to thee to the poor and we'll
say the can we have the money back she
broke off the correspondence at that
point which is very typical of her why
did you write the book well because I
couldn't believe that anyone else had
start again I couldn't believe that
nobody else had taken to say I can't get
this right I could was impossible for me
to let such a fat target go by I mean he
was he was someone but whom no one had
taken the second look whose publicity
was always favorable not to say adoring
yet who was all the time in the company
of dictators and crooks and frauds and
bullies of all kinds and who was
preaching a very very very reactionary
kind of religious fundamentalism while
being universally called a saint I
thought the gap between these two things
was so great that it merited a short
book and so it's got in there all the
things that you don't know but Mother
Teresa but should this is the second
printing of the book it's just coming to
paperback available with fine bookstores
I believe everywhere now you write that
contraception and abortion are morally
equivalent that's the view of Mother
Teresa cruisers though and you also
write about what you described as her
crimes against humanity what are they
well she went to for Japan's capital of
Haiti during the devaglia
made a long and groveling speech saying
how how nice the Duvalier family were to
the poor of Haiti accepting in return a
decoration and medal from them and
justifying their regime she's done the
same for quite a lot of other
dictatorships around the world for mrs.
Gandhi in India for and Rohan sure in
Albania she's she's preached that in
Ireland that there should be no divorce
and no contraception which of course
only deepens the religious split in
Ireland absolutely the last thing the
Irish people need as well as denying the
right of family planning and divorce to
Irish people though she has praised a
Princess Diana for getting out of her
own marriage because she's become a
friend of Princess Diana so that's all
right because as is not untypical of
people like her she's a seller of
indulgences to the very rich while a
preacher of resignation and submission
to the poor who she's helped chiefly so
it's a pretty long bill of indictment I
noticed that the Congress is about to
get selected build medal in her honour
and I absolutely can't believe that no
one will get up and say that what are we
doing here in March of this past year
you wrote this editorial yes I'm gonna
use this as a segue you wrote that now
in her ninth decade after having spread
her benevolent legacy around the world
Mother Teresa awaits her reward the
ongoing challenge to the rest of us is
not merely to be inspired by her
exemplary works but to institutionalize
them so I suspected yes I did write that
I did write that this was on occasion of
her stepping down as the Mother Superior
of her group to this woman I the example
the argument I make and I just I
actually read this book and it is funny
and you Christopher
you get about ten more of these and you
could have your own version of eminent
Victorians which will keep you alive in
the 22nd century it memory-wise but I
mean I also think that long after I'm
forgotten and mother Teresa will be a
saint and the fact that all that she did
in Calcutta and doing things that very
few people want to do which is which is
get with get with lepers preach Bishop
should be limited well it should be
limitless population well look I think
the Catholic Church is got as a
political entity is not been as
effective and constructive as a moral
religious entity
and I mean the Pope I'm a big fan of the
sort of social democrat at heart
yeah and I'm more of a free-market here
so with but just there's there's such a
thing beyond transcending politics of
this moral example but may i else do
this
leaving the questions neutral how do you
know that she's done anything any good
in Calcutta I mean everyone thinks they
know that she's devoted her life to the
poor of Calcutta what can they actually
say they know about this she said she
said it bran
she moved at the age of 17 she left
Albania to go to Ireland with the
sisters of Loretto and then went to
India and she's been a missionary
alright nights people believe that she
is feeding the hungry in Bengal don't
they they believe she's clothing the
naked now I asked in my book we know
she's been given a very great deal of
money we know that the standard of her
clinics into a hospice for the dying in
Calcutta is very near gutter level
there's no there's no treatment there
there's no medicine people go there to
die so the money hasn't been spent on
that she has claimed her to have open
several hundred convents and rest
different parts of the world I suspect
since she won't allow an audit and she
went she wouldn't give back the stolen
money that Charles Keating gave to her
or answer questions about it that all
the money that good people like yourself
who believe in her sainthood Center has
simply been spent in building a monument
to Catholic fundamentalism well I guess
we'd have a different perception of what
the value of her work has been I mean I
mean certainly people like Jerry Brown
for example who went over spent some
period of time helping out and many
others have come away terribly moved and
pressed like anything as I say about the
Marshall Plan there's more than one way
to interpret interpret this I I do think
that it is ironic that at a time when
feminism for example is searching for
role models and finding ways to per
ticket to the patriarchs that the the
most remarkable ongoing successful model
of feminist empowerment feminine
empowerment has been Catholic nuns over
the over the millennia and it's it's
quite something and Mother Teresa is
only the latest in a long line well she
does say that when she got the Nobel
Prize she said abortion was the greatest
threat to world peace
I'm very squeamish about abortion myself
but it's it's hysterically wrong to say
that it's the greatest
to world peace and it's I think it's
absolutely wicked to say that it's
morally equivalent to contraception or
artificial contraception zuv catholic
church calls it as if there was any
other kind
I think it's wicked for to campaign
against the right of women women in
Ireland would be married to wife beaters
and drunks and child abusers who want to
divorce them and say if you try to get
remarried we will never forgive it we
will never forgive you but forgiveness
by all means for Charles Keating
forgiveness for the Duvalier family
forgiveness for Union Carbide at Bhopal
after they poisoned the people of India
there forgive forgive forgive every time
when it's the rich sale of indulgences
and strict Stern disciplined clerical
control over sex to the poor and to the
gender which you say she's empowering
I've never heard such concentrated
nonsense in my life you mentioned Jerry
Brown a LA Times article reprinted this
morning in the Baltimore Sun he's
thinking about running for mayor of
Oakland California let's get a call from
Essex County New Jersey good morning
good morning I'm appalled at mr.
Hitchens positions on just about
everything one of the most they were
devastating one is that mr. Nixon with
President Nixon was incapable of writing
a book he's the one who brought down the
Soviet biggest lobby I think he referred
to President Reagan not President Nixon
I meant Reagan of course I'm so excited
and upset I'm sorry yes of course
President Reagan he negotiated without
somebody whispering in his ear with the
world leaders and had their respect a
large and large amount of respect and
this president has ever received is
justified Lee so he may be clever mr.
Clinton but I think Pacific President
Reagan was a man of vision who
understood the world understood and had
principles and with those principles but
America in the forefront after the
disaster of a Carter regime and in his
mother Teresa position those are
religious stands there are not none of
your business you're obviously an
atheist and all your positions are on
the left so whatever you're saying is
tainted and tainted okay
response which is right on the certain
point obviously I mean I don't believe
that I'm here as the handiwork of God or
that my actions are supervised by a
supernatural intelligence of any kind
and I think it's extreme arrogance in on
the part of anyone who does believe that
they're oddly enough people to go around
saying that they do God's work of the
out God's creatures for this piece of
conceit are always called extremely
modest and humble I don't know why on
the first point we won't have time to go
over our differences about President
Reagan now you probably guess I don't
agree with your account of him but even
if your account was correct now the fact
remains that he did not write his and
then was it in my judgment could not
have read that neither do you believe in
any other greater force in this universe
no Jim Pinkerton about you oh you know I
think there isn't that's a tough
question questions it's a question for
Sunday morning I'll have to what what
what why why did why today of all days
to get into well look you can say you
believe in the power of love which is
something that can't be quantified for
example it was obviously not a
measurable force you can say you believe
in it and you can see as it has so to
speak worked but that is a product of
human emotion and intellect and energy
and character and it's not you one
doesn't need a supernatural explanation
for it and I might nor does one any
longer need one for the origins of the
cosmos and we no longer can conceal
ourselves that we are the century even
to a of a galaxy let alone own the
universe so I'm afraid that probably
probably the this supposedly modest but
actually arrogant belief that we're
children of God is is as discredited as
the idea that the universe was created
for our convenience I do think we make a
point though and that is that I mean
whatever chambers perhaps best express
the idea that the kind of stoic atheism
which you express and I mean stoic in
the sense of just the Greek sense is
very hard to maintain it kind of says
look we are here as bits a bits of
matter in the universe the danger that
you fall into this Chesterton said is
that if you don't believe in anything
then you believe everything and the
problem of the century has not been too
many Catholics and too many Mother
Teresa's the problem is
too many Nazis and communists all of
whom I think sought to replace God with
something else mostly their own egos and
their own historical theories and so the
risk you face is that is that in this is
the spiritually desolate world that you
create you will wind up with towers of
Babel built out of bureaucrats and
gremlins would you grow up
Chicago Evanston Illinois anyway to
school at George Washington University
no I went to Stanford what did you come
to Washington 1980 you lecture George
Washington I read it wrong here what did
you first get involved in Republican
Party politics um really with the Reagan
campaign way back when in 79 and 80 in
California fax from a viewer in
California says mr. Pinkerton may I ask
how tall are you
you look fabulous I am 5 foot 10 my
husband and three sons are six four six
five yes they're all tall ones I'm six
nine I drank a lot of milk when I was a
kid did you play basketball no I was
never really good for the most often as
I wanted most often and I will even say
obvious questions asked but but to no
avail
to be fair christopher hitchens how tall
are you 510 I think and we're not the
same size as the lady of the facts would
you grow high in England until I was
about 30 or so mainly in London and in
Oxford who shapes you're a Navy brat we
moved around a lot now huh
born in Portsmouth who helps to shape
your ideas I mean what do you read where
do you go for information how do your
books and columns all come about I'm
gonna ask you the same question in a
moment gosh I wish I'd had we should ask
him first my good knee and I could have
played for time well I think the great
thing about being a journalist is the
public has on paying for education with
the rest of your life and in theory
everything you do is work and the best
recommendation one it is to be try and
be interested in everything and to read
like an omnivore is there is there a
particular author or authors
current or historian types that you
often refer to yes I find I'm always
referring to
Karl Marx of course and Rosa Luxemburg
weren't surprised someone might retract
Esther here but to George Orwell I found
repeatedly recurring to him and to his
writing it's been noticed in fact in my
columns I'm trying to hold it down
because he he so often came up with the
right sentence and very often Oscar
Wilde for some reason I could elaborate
on that if you like certain becoming
because he's much more than the the
light-hearted playwright that he's
considered to be he wrote some quite
profound stuff on on politics and on
culture came across a brilliant thing he
wrote about Ireland the other day as a
matter of fact where he predicted that
it wouldn't be very long before the
United States became the most important
country in deciding the future of our
than something the British didn't
understand then wouldn't have understood
then even now don't really are not
really quite ready to accept it has been
true most of the century in fact the
United States is the main player in our
house here aware that in the late 1880s
I'm very aware of having knowledge do a
question in an unsatisfactory way I
should have I should have thought of
well you've had time to think about it
now you can answer the same question I'm
fairly early on you know when you're a
kid with no friends you I sat around in
red Gibbons of decline of all the Roman
Empire which gave me a super case of
Anglo philia a way back when and will so
great texts against Christianity it
actually it is you're right it is how
that notwithstanding it is even a
greater text of just we've been down
these roads before we've made these
mistakes before you know the past is a
way of recruiting in the end of the
present and into the future and it just
gives you a sense that nothing that we
create is permanent that you can screw
it up and have it all come tumbling down
on you it's sort of a tragic sense of
history which actually marks as some
extent has to but I guess if since we're
both struggling with what's a the most
infernal question of all which is the
open-ended question which enables you to
make a fool of yourself I'm babbling
forever
I mean the point to any viewer who could
possibly learn anything from the show or
would might even be interested to it
would be read history yes that will tell
you a lot Morgan's it
less Sociology more history warren
Pennsylvania's our next caller good
morning good morning I'd like to ask mr.
Hitchens if there he plans on going to
kind of see anytime soon to go to the
little cafe who's selling the mother
Teresa the nun bun things I I just think
he should go there and support that
gentleman and I think he's 100% right
about her it was written up this past
week somewhere wasn't it go yes the
nashville the nashville the mother trees
are on a roll right someone bought a
cinnamon roll came to see her features
on this roll in a they started
franchising into this cafe in nashville
and now her lawyers mother teresa's laws
you won't be surprised to hear she's got
some quite high powered ones and she's
very keen on controlling franchising
i've told him to cease and desist have
you ever met mother teresa yeah I went
to go away to Calcutta to meet her and
how much time did you spend with her she
gave me a tour of her operation was very
very small and underfunded one mainly
for propaganda purposes and when she'd
finished showing me this tiny orphanage
that she had which is nice enough
there's an orphanage but she with a wave
of her arms she said you see this is how
we combat abortion and contraception in
Bengal and I thought well it's
interesting I might have suspected that
her main motive was for religious
propaganda but she was confirming it
without being asked that was I think
when I began to think maybe someone
should take a second look at this this
outfit and indeed it this woman from
another viewer mr. Pinkerton please
explain this nutty idea of NATO
expansion well I think I said I'm
against it so I'm not necessarily person
asked President Clinton's argument is
that NATO has been the most successful
peacekeeping alliance in European
history and if it makes sense to have
Germany and France and
the other country Italy and in NATO that
it also makes sense to have the Czech
Republic and Poland and Hungary and to
be sure that the poles Hungarians and
the Czechs who have suffered more than
their share of oppression from various
invading armies and countries and so on
are strongly for it I think the better
argument though is that NATO is built as
an anti con anti Soviet
alliance which and it did its work of
course the Soviet Union doesn't exist
anymore so that attenuates the need for
NATO and it's much better to bring not
only Poland Hungary in the Czech
Republic but also all the rest of these
countries you know the Baltic States for
example into a non-military more
peaceful economic oriented alliance such
as the European Economic Community
there's also it's in today's paper as a
matter of fact a very interesting story
when mr. Gorbachev was the head of
affairs in the Soviet Union and met with
James Baker the crucial question was the
reunification of Germany would Russia
permit what it had always feared with
such suspicion to occur peacefully and
mr. Baker assured him that it would be
in his interest to do so which I think
mr. Ghosh l4a believed more than half
believed adding that in case he was
worried about it the United States could
could guarantee that NATO had no further
designs
if mr. Gorbachev allowed Germany in
other words to stay within NATO as
reunified that would mark the the
eastward limit of nature's frontier and
that that promise was repeated several
times and believed by the Russians who
are now obviously very suspicious of the
word and the other guarantees that come
with the the next round grab another
call Erie Pennsylvania good morning
Frank darling I'd like to comment in
lieutenant Flynn's case okay lieutenant
when the Europe a bypass the most
serious charge there when you say that
the adultery thing the adultery was
committed with the spouse of a
subordinate that's the equivalent the
military incest all right that is the
most serious charge you can't that that
strikes at the very heart of the
military
the other two charges the refusal to
stop it and then lying about it would
have put a man in Leavenworth there's no
question in my mind and as for mr.
Hutchinson is strung out 50 destroyers
let me tell you something those 50
destroyers were equal to the register
stories of the period they were built in
1918 1917 period and we're practically
brand-new
because they're all out of commission by
the early 20s excuse me a little nervous
that's okay let's get an answer from
both of our guests we'll start with you
well I do think that the Kelley Flynn
case certainly communicates the
hypocrisy the feminist movement I mean
Kelly Flynn is got her act together
she's smart enough to get herself on the
front page of the New York Times and the
cover of Time magazine and she's got it
there's a Kelly Flynn web page she's got
a whole slew of lawyers and so her story
can get out there first
and meanwhile air woman Zygo the wife of
the this this philandering soccer player
in North Dakota she comes along and says
look this woman stole my husband and
nobody nobody seems to give her story as
much attention and so I do think that
again the Air Force made a mistake I
kind of agree with what the the military
incest is I don't really agree with but
the general accusation that yes Flynn
has no business being in the Air Force I
agree and the Air Force is going to get
an enormous black eye out of this for in
its own sort of ham-handed way trying to
defend what I do think is a legitimate
notion of the chain of command when that
call came through a groan from
Christopher Hitchens why but I just I
can't get excited about this guy
Congress eyes about any of these
arguments but where babies come from I
do I do think there should be more
gazing into the tree maybe that would
help I think it was a big mistake for
Clinton to climb down on that quite
apart from the civil and human rights
aspect oh it was quite wrong to let it
which I have for a president to let
himself be dictated to by the Joint
Chiefs there's enough military
interference in politics in this country
as it is anything else on the morning
newspaper well I owe the gentleman an
answer on the lend-lease question I
think when I said clapped-out I may have
been harsh or sarcastic but as you
confirm
they may be in good condition but there
were very much superannuated vessels and
the British with that station defied a
very tough war in the Atlantic and the
North Sea and the English Channel
against the the Nazi Marine and second
you have challenged my point a notice
which was my main point which is for
every bit of that aid that Roosevelt
offered he secured either for example
the transfer of British gold reserves
from South Africa to Washington or the
making over of British naval bases in
the in the West Indies or West Africa or
some other very large concession
Churchill at one point compared
Roosevelt to if they hated each other
it's complete myth that this beautiful
friendship they had compared him to a
church Helen Roosevelt loathed each
other well judge I think despised of
stroke Rosa I think despised Churchill
but Churchill really resented Roosevelt
and described him as some a sheriff
collecting the the last belongings of a
hapless debtor what about all these
stories of their time at the White House
though in all the many weeks that
Churchill spent in this country for the
birds for the special people who
believed in the special relationship
anything else when were morning papers
well I just this is an ad in today's
Washington Post for years and years the
AL Shanker the late president of the
United Federation of Teachers ran an ad
in The New York Times where we stand and
I guess the Bob chase from the National
Education Association has taken up the
same business and I mean to me this is
just any a propaganda core it is an
advertisement so I guess it's their it's
their money but he's trying to make the
argument that the NEA is moving into the
future as the United mind M IND workers
and it's just you know three columns of
propaganda about the NEA without all the
elements that actually communicate an
information-rich high-tech entity which
is competition choice entrepreneurship
none of which the NEA supports all of us
should oppose is and much more useful to
anybody interested in education is this
article in the upcoming
Weekly Standard about just what a dead
monopoly public education is in this
country thanks in large measure to
it's a National Education Association
education also the cover story of the
Weekly Standard christopher hitchens i
read the cover story
it's buggered Himmelfarb isn't it about
how professors talk only about their own
exploits and everything's me me me and
III that seems to be true it's actually
true of the whole culture at the moment
everyone's talking in the first person
and me decade was supposed to be the
eighties but this looks like being their
series that's what the semi means I need
a head of 70s right I mean that's a
problem with the real Narcisse of
nourishment always seems to be a bit of
a pile of narcissism but it really seems
to be out of control now contributing
editor for Vanity Fair columnist with
the Nation magazine doing that for about
15 years what else you working seniors
in June it'll be my god man and boy
that's it at the moment I'm not doing
anything with my left hand I'm doing a
bit of signing and promoting for the
mother Teresa but that's it and Jim pick
your time what else what else are you
doing I'm write a column for a news
today I'm on the Fox channel sometimes
and I teach part-time at George
Washington University would you ever
like to go back and work at the in
another Republican White House I wrote a
book two years ago called what comes
next which I endorsed not only school
vouchers and usual Republican stuff but
also endorsed gay marriage and so I
don't I would tell anybody wants to hire
me read the book first and if you still
want me after that give me a call
James Pinkerton because super Hitchens
always a pleasure thank you very much
for being with us
stay with us good for just a moment if
you want to talk about tough duty Danny
Farkas probably has one of the best
assignments at least here at c-span he's
joining us on the phone from Oahu Hawaii
and what we're looking at now is the C
span school bus as it comes off a
molasses ship it was encased in blue
canvas and it travelled from
California's west coast to Hawaii it
took a number of days and is now in
Hawaii this marks the 50th state that
the c-span school bus has visited
promoting this network and also talking
about education in all this year talking
about Alexis de Tocqueville Danny Farkas
good morning to you good morning what
time is it there now it's about 2004 a
them we're looking at the pictures now
that you've taken over the last couple
of days Oh what's on the agenda for the
next few days well we've got a live
event on Monday morning we're going to
be showing a ceremony from the USS
Arizona on Memorial Day when they're
doing the ceremony there are sunken ship
out in the middle of the harbor and then
on Tuesday we're going to be once again
working with oceanic Cablevision and Oh
lay low which is a corporation for
community television here and then I
guess a couple more days after that
we'll be heading to Maui we have two
buses on the road why why well it's a
really so we can cover all the
requesting cover the country like we
like to be able to do all the requests
being from the cable systems that would
like to have the bus come by for a visit
how many cable systems are there in
Hawaii and how many homes are wired well
there are actually about three hundred
and thirty thousand subscribers on all
of Hawaii that can get c-span and as far
as cable systems here on Oahu we've got
Time Warner owned group called oceanic
cable vision and on Maui we've got TCI
and then there's a couple of other
smaller systems Hawaiian television and
as I mentioned Oh Layla which is not a
cable system but its corporate for
community television which is really
sort of co-sponsoring the event with
oceanic cable vision here on Oahu how
many people live in Hawaii believe ye
has a little over a million 1 million
one hundred thousand eight and 229
people as far as the 1990 census goes is
this your first time there this is not
my first time here I was here one time
previous your observations on the the
island state I'd say gorgeous obviously
as everyone says I was chastised a
little yesterday at our stop for being
the only person on the island wearing a
tie so I'd say it's slightly more
laid-back than the mainland but other
than that it's just really such a huge
amount of natural beauty here it is
something that everyone should see at
some point and explained again I
mentioned earlier to travel on a
molasses ship how did that all come
about well I did a little research into
what were the options as far as getting
a 45 foot long custom coach from the
mainland to of Hawaii and there were not
that many options the quickest option
was taking what they called molasses
tanker which is a ship owned by the
Matson Navigation corporation and it
they said is the quickest only took us
about four and a half days to get from
LA to Honolulu unfortunately nobody got
to ride on the boat so except the bus
but it was a pretty interesting process
they actually weren't carrying any
molasses this time because they don't
usually bring it from the mainland to
Hawaii
it's obviously brought from Hawaii back
to the mainland so in a weaker and a
half here so when we head back it will
be riding with molasses in the forecast
for the next few days make us all feel
bad oh it's sunny and beautiful of
course
about 80 to 85 degrees I'd say every day
with a little shower usually once a day
at some point the pennant clears right
back up Danny Farkas a part of our
c-span school bus team in Hawaii and of
course we'll have live coverage starting
at about 1:00 o'clock tomorrow afternoon
from Pearl Harbor where there will be
ceremonies commemorating Memorial Day
also some programming before and
afterwards looking at Hawaii its economy
its role in military and a little bit of
its history is the 50th state and the
50th stop for the sea spent school but
standing Farkus thanks very much thank
you very much agents go e have eaten
have either have you been in Hawaii
yeah goodness I never have wonderful
Abijah wahoo in time let that's that's
what Pearl Harbor is it is as a matter
of fact I was I was in Pearl Harbor on
the day that Ronald Reagan made a speech
saying hey the Japanese should know they
were running the risk of a trade war and
be they should be paying more of their
own defense budget and I remember
thinking one or the other but not both I
think we thought would have occurred to
me if I hadn't been in one we talked
earlier about the new record that is
being set today senator Strom Thurmond
Republican of South Carolina who is now
the longest serving u.s. senator in
history and also the oldest ever to
serve in the US Senate he is 94 years
old and Lew Ketchum did an interview
within this past week which runs about
17 minutes but first from the Senate
floor two of his colleagues senator
Hollings also from South Carolina and
Senator Arlen Specter paying tribute to
Senator Strom Thurmond which today marks
his anniversaries we continue c-span's
Washington journal on this Sunday